es ist schwer abzuschätzen wie viel ich
über die jahre geklaut habe aber ich
denke es sachen im wert von drei bis
fünf millionen euro
wie machen wir das wenn wir also dorthin
wo wir menschen auf der erde doch
eigentlich alle das gleiche wollen etwas
lernen unserem leben wir wollen zeigen
dass sie etwas besonders gut drauf haben
wollen vielleicht erfolg haben oder eine
familie gründen so ist es doch
eigentlich bei uns ein
nicht ganz
nicht ganz das ist vielleicht bei euch
so dass es mit sicherheit bei mir so
aber ich habe im internet eine junge
dame gefunden bei der die ganze sache
ein bisschen anders ist und zwar ist die
vollzeit die bin also die gegen die
arbeiten die cloud sich einfach alles
zusammen was sie braucht ich glaube an
der stelle können wir mal karin ritter
um ihre meinung bitten
ritter bitte ich würde gar nicht
angehoben leute wir schauen uns heute
das video luxusleben als die bilder an
und bevor wir loslegen noch zwei sachen
leute folgten auf instagram at s kids
und auch wenn sich das wie gefällt euch
mich freuen wenn ihr jetzt aber immer
wieder drin oder am ende einen kanal
abonniert werden kurz vor den 6000
abonnenten also jeder abonnent herzlich
willkommen denn wir das geklärt worden
letztes kind farians tochter paris leben
dieser formel täglich hängen sie in
coolen boutiquen im londoner
nobelviertel chelsea hat zu hause
stapeln sich die schicken teile also
soweit noch alles okay leute hätte man
die tiere jetzt noch nicht gelesen
könnte man vielleicht sogar davon
ausgehen dass es sich um eine frau
handeln die irgendwo auf demselben
planeten lebt wie wir wissen was ich
meine sofern der einstellung zum leben
hier so nach dem motto ich muss erst was
leisten damit ich da irgendwas bekomme
aber offensichtlicher weise ist es ja
nicht so aber keinen einzigen cent dafür
ausgegeben alles ist geklaut
es ist schwer abzuschätzen wie viel ich
über die jahre geklaut habe das ist
nochmal applaus welt im ferry englands
30 7 hat soviel geklauten im leben sie
weiß gar nicht mehr wie sie geklaut hat
legende dr
ja ohne witz so 30 muss man erst mal
sein dass erstmal zu machen überhaupt
das könnte ich schon mal gar nicht
und dann auch noch so ins ferne zu gehen
und sagen ja
zusammen
wie wie machen wir das wie schafft man
es in seinem leben überhaupt auf diesen
materialwert zu kommen an anzeigen ohne
einfach kraft lang im knast zu sein weil
irgendwie zum 20 mal am klauen erwischt
wird es gibt nur eine erklärung dafür
leute kim ferry muss irgendwo entlang
des weges auch häuser geklaut haben also
wenn ihr diese junge dame in der nähe
ihres hauses oder ihrer wohnung sieht
passt auf sie könnte am nächsten tag weg
sein kind fing schon mit 99 zu klauen
erst für ihre mutter später für die
eigene familie ihre 14-jährige tochter
paris lebte wie die made im speck im
geklauten speck bitte darf also wir
wollen noch bei der wahl bleibt in
geklauten spät ich wusste schon dass das
alles geklärt war dass das nicht ehrlich
ist
aber naja ich war immer total glücklich
weil ich jeden tag was neues zum
anziehen geschenkt bekam
perfekt oder also auf den moralischen
level kann man dazu überhaupt nichts
sagen das ist natürlich alles moralisch
einwandfrei ich freue mich auch immer
wieder über geldbeträge die ich von
meinen freunden geschenkt bekommen habe
also ich weiß dass das geld aus
handtaschen von omas kommt die dafür auf
die straße geschubst worden aber ich
meine das geld ist es schade weil wir
jetzt mal wieder leute wie kann man so
eine ekelhafte einstellung haben aber so
verdammt ist okay wenn ich ein bisschen
würde zu englands dreiste diebin fing an
auch auf bestellung zu stehlen
da wird verdiente sie sich locker 7000
euro in der woche leute was mache ich
falsch
was mache ich falsch was machen wir
falsch so gut ich bin youtube ist alles
zu den ganz normalen beruf aller zeiten
aber worte [ __ ] einfach clown auf
bestellung bis zu einer party so jo heim
sebastian ich bin maschinenbau
hey ich glaub bestellung designertaschen
habe ich mir einfach rum gehängt und
werden dann raus gegangen
der mantel hier hätte 150 euro gekostet
und für den hier hätte ich 1000 bezahlen
müssen
ok also das ist haben wir ihre massen so
dass sie einfach so packen dreißig sag
das wort jetzt einfach mal dass leute
gar nicht denken dass das geklaut sein
könnte also sie hängt sich die ganzen
sache einfach erzählt sie sich scheinbar
an und möchte damit einfach raus nichts
war vor mir sicher ich ließ geschirr
mitgehen silberbesteck vorhänge spiegel
oder bilder ganz egal
und vielleicht auch das haus ihrer
eltern oder die wohnung nicht sicher vor
kim ferry unser glück ganz ehrlich als
deutsche dass die schon bei aus
großbritannien kommt und da bisher
geklaut hat wenn die mal tritt nach köln
macht da ist der kölner dom oder sowas
von weg solange ich es ihm eine große
tasche stecken konnte oder ist mit
meinen händen tragen konnte man alles
kein problem
wann kommt der part wo sie irgendwie so
dafür entschuldigt oder rechtfertigt
oder sagt dass es nicht so der richtige
weg ist oder bleibt jetzt einfach dabei
so ich kann den ganzen tag über egal die
sind eh alle versicherten und die holen
sich das wieder die haben keinen
wirklichen verlust und ganz ehrlich
also haben das unternehmen verdient
beklaut zu werden also quasi auch
kleinere familien geschäfte müssen wir
nicht noch mal eben die in
familienbesitz sind und die vielleicht
für die schulbildung der kinder zahlen
die haben natürlich auch verdient weil
ja warum sie haben es verdient so wie
die uns kunden abzocken mittleren
überhöhten preisen
gott sei dank die retterin der modernen
welt die retterin der menschen im
kapitalismus es zu stellen die leute im
ferry dankeschön kim dass uns die arbeit
abnimmt was das für einen irrweg so du
zahlst ja offensichtlich keine über
preise wo ist die rechtfertigung dafür
dass du klaust kann mir mal einer sagen
oder cloud die weil wir über höhere
preise zahlen
also wir zeigen kann sich damit die
klagen kann kim zog auch dumm aber die
polizei haben hier schließlich doch auf
die spur tochter paris erinnert sich mit
schrecken an die letzte festnahme okay
für mein persönliches gefühl für meine
stimmung in diesem moment und dafür dass
ich es meinem bildschirm einschlage geht
die frau wurde immerhin schon mal
festgenommen werden jetzt könnte es ohne
mitleid stories einkaufte vor so schlimm
ist die polizei beantragt warum machen
die so was mit uns in den laden in der
gesamten stadt aus gehören hast ich
hatte so angst dass sie wieder ins
gefängnis muss kemmer insgesamt
siebenmal hinter gittern kein
kinderspiel für die kleine paris sieben
mal im gefängnis
okay das war ein bisschen mehr
gerechtigkeit für uns dummköpfe die
überhöhte preise zahlt reagierte ich
denke darüber nach so vielleicht ist die
kleptomanin das gibt es zum
krankheitsbild das müssen leute diese
zwanghaft klauen müssen aber
andererseits hat die auch irgend so eine
moralische rechtfertigung für das was
sie macht wissen was mein und sagte ja
ich mache das weil die form erhöhter
preise
ich habe ihretwegen ein schlechtes
gewissen obwohl sie immer klartext es
nichts ausmacht aber es muss schlimm für
sie gewesen sein sie hat sich bestimmt
eine normale mutter mit einem normalen
job gewünscht
filme auf gar keinen fall nun macht
einfach dein ding weiter weiß auch ein
14 jähriges kind seine mutter sehen
natürlich hat ein 14 jähriges kind keine
lust darauf hat sich sorgen darum machen
zu müssen ob die mutter morgen wieder im
knast geht oder nicht natürlich nicht
das ist genau das was 14 jährige kinder
wollen eltern die im knast sind und
unsicherheit
erst jetzt ist klar dass ich ihr schade
weil die leute sie meinetwegen
verurteilen um dem ganzen ein ende zu
bereiten als ich kenne jetzt öffentlich
als kriminelle geoutet muss man das
verstehen einerseits okay die frau ist
doch jetzt schon über 50 habe ich mich
irgendwie so haben sie mal gesagt der
sogar 15 so ok und dann jetzt vor kurzem
kann mir die erkenntnis
moment mal das könnte vielleicht
schlecht auf meine tochter abfärben mit
was mit 48 kam so der gedanke und dann
natürlich als thema erkannt hat dass ihr
image schlecht ob ihre tochter abwehrt
was macht sie da sie gibt ihr verbrechen
im nationalen fernsehen zu damit noch
mehr menschen ihre tochter verteilen
könnt bin so froh dass sie jetzt mit dem
spielen aufgehört hat ich will nicht
dass wir noch mal ins gefängnis muss sie
wird nicht immer so viel glück haben ja
okay also von glück zu reden wenn man
schon sieben mal im knast saß
das ist ein bisschen optimistisch meiner
meinung nach aber so oder so und ich
habe ein bisschen mitleid mit wie es die
paris nice cars also wenn man eine
mutter hat die erst mit ende 40 auf die
geniale idee kommt dass ihre eigene
kriminelle lebenseinstellung schlecht
habe ihre tochter abfärbt sorry paris an
der stelle für dich hätte auch das neue
ehrliche leben des staates kein luxus
mehr freunde und familie die früher von
kind streifzügen profitierten haben den
kontakt abgebrochen
habt ihr das gesehen leute acht um mein
gott
ich glaube ich glaube ich habe gerade
gesehen das ist ein karton
die arme die abo paris muss jetzt nike
tragen statt louie vito und gucci
[Musik]
zumindest hat die arbeitslose kim jetzt
mehr zeit für ihre tochter paris apa
geburtstag und geht immer noch gerne
shoppen aber von der sozialhilfe kann
ihre wut es sowas nicht kaufen
ok ja macht sinn so weit also klar kann
man von sozialhilfe keine teuren
klamotten kaufen die frage ist natürlich
was macht ihr in diesem klamottenladen
tim k
die versuchung ist groß aber kein will
jetzt eisern bleiben vor allem für peres
ich habe jetzt schon seit 13 wochen
nichts mehr gestohlen
13 wochen
das ist gar nicht mal so eine lange zeit
viel spaß gehabt ich weiß nicht wie das
ist heute wahrscheinlich ist es wirklich
wieso eine sucht wenn man einfach so
gewohnt ist zu klauen folgen in der
größe allzu platt ist zwar eine aussage
dazu stolz auf bis zwölf wochen nicht
geklaut zu haben aber in einer situation
trotzdem keinen applaus
ja das war zwar ein video zum thema
clown aber wenn ihr an der stelle
vielleicht doch lust habt was zu geben
anstatt zu nehmen würde ich mich freuen
wenn ihr meinen kanal abonniert mir auf
instagram folgt es versorgt und
natürlich gibt's wie immer für alle von
euch die gerne weiter schauen wollt hier
ein völlig vorgeschlagenes bio leute das
war's so weit von mir ich größere augen
macht's gut